russia's defense ministry says it's
reached a deal to evacuate wounded
ukrainian soldiers from the besieged
azov style steel plant in the
southeastern port of mariopol moscow
says the ceasefire was in effect and
that a humanitarian corridor would be
established to allow injured fighters to
leave the steelworks though they would
be taken to a town held by pro-moscow
separatists for treatment
ukrainian forces in the northeast have
mounted a counter attack pushing russian
troops away from the settings from the
second largest city kharkiv there's also
heavy fighting in the eastern region of
luhansk where residents are still
reluctant to leave
ukrainian tanks and heavy artillery on
their way to the luhansk region russia
has increasingly turned its attention to
eastern ukraine but the ukrainians are
making preparations
one of the cities the artillery is going
to is lizzy chansk
not everyone there is ready to leave
despite the russian threat
tell me seriously what are you doing
here with the children do you understand
that this is a war zone
right now we have to avoid shelling and
make our way through a very difficult
situation in order to reach the people
but people just sit here and think
everything will be fine unfortunately
everything is not fine
angelina abacoumova has been living in a
bunker for over a month with her two
children she doesn't believe the police
can bring them to safety
i know so many people who were evacuated
and then simply dropped off on the
street i do not think leaving is an
option
only 20 kilometers away lies the town of
robishni
russian state tv claims that it's under
russian control
but the ukrainian military says it still
has reason to celebrate it says its
troops have pushed russia from the
northeastern city of hal keith and
advanced as far as the border with
russia
nato has said that ukraine can win this
war
russia's war
in ukraine is not going as moscow had
planned
they failed to take yep
they are pulling back from around
kharkiv
major offensive in donbass has stalled
russia is not achieving its strategic
objectives
and ukraine has received another moral
boost from the country's win in the
eurovision song contest
even in the most dire conditions like
here in a bunker below the azo style
steelworks and mario pole some soldiers
perform the winning song
[Music]
well dw correspondent uh is in kiev i
asked her about the deal announced by
russia that would see injured ukrainian
soldiers evacuated from the
steelworks to russian controlled
territory
well that offer definitely raised some
eyebrows among ordinary ukrainians here
because they cannot imagine
regardless whether these uh as of
regiment soldiers are wounded or not
that they really want to hand themselves
basically over to the aggressor to
russia that's been pounding the as of
steel plant for weeks now however i've
been speaking to a sister of one of
these soldiers just yesterday and she
said that people really inside that
steel plant are in such dire condition
that maybe this could be a way to vacuum
evacuate people but really the last
resort in fact a lot of people are
hoping the relatives that is the third
country for example turkey and turkey
made that offer as well to extract
soldiers
bring them to turkey as long as this
rule continues also if you zoom in on
that offer russia basically says we will
make sure that there is a humanitarian
corridor but the soldiers the wounded
soldiers and medics will be evacuated to
russian controlled territory about 40
kilometers from mario paul
for now what we know is from a social
media post basically that a senior
commander of the as of regiment is
saying that a decision is currently
being made about saving lives now does
does it mean that the siege is over
there's no word about surrendering and i
really think that the next hours are
going to be crucial in many ways whether
those wounded soldiers say they are
ready to give it a try to say so even
though they risked their lives with that
as well not knowing what russian
forces are going to do with them or are
they going to stay inside the steel
plant after all these people here have
been described as heroes trying to
defend what's left of
ukrainian-controlled mario paul and
that's not much
and and how would you say the russian
offensive is proceeding
especially with its apparent refocusing
on don bass
ever since basically they are sold here
on kiev ram right now on the key free
gen on chair and heath and the northern
parts of ukraine didn't work out to
really refocus on the donbass region
which vladimir putin the president in
russia described just recently once
again as motherland clearly implying
they want to fight for the donbass
region now as the momentum clearly
shifts towards ukraine because after all
during the past couple of days they've
made some serious advancements in the
archive region as well which is also
strategically quite important for russia
neighboring the donbass region it seems
like the tide seems to be turning for
the ukrainian forces after all they were
seen as quite inferior when this war has
begun through three months ago so all
the mobilization there from russian
forces is right now in the donbass
region and this is unfortunately the
civilians are really bearing the brunt
of heavy shelling we are talking about
civilian infrastructure about schools
about hospitals being attacked and this
is where the entire war has been
shifting right now apart from murray
pool apart from hearthstone odessa and
the southern part of ukraine however all
around certainly
nobody expected in fact that the russian
invasion is is basically going to derail
as we see right now happening but does
it mean the end of the war
soon in fact this is the only thing that
both russia and ukraine can agree on at
this point that nobody knows how long
this war is going to continue okay thank
you for that dw correspondent at funding
for shah in kiev